hey guys it's Greg Alva here it's John
Humphrey over here so we found out not
long ago at chester bennington from
lincoln and mark passed away due to
suicide he had had six children children
- from two different why he's only 41
years old years old there and honestly
this came as a major shock to both of us
mm-hmm you know yeah because a lot of
times you hear about like celebrity fake
deaths that con I was thinking maybe
this is one of those yeah but it's been
confirmed yeah Mike Mike Shinoda went on
Twitter and then basically said like we
don't have a statement yet but but this
is true it's shocking yeah it's really
shocking because it's he's pretty young
to pass away and be Linkin Park we don't
really talk about music on this channel
but if anyone's ever seen us talk about
music you know that John and I have like
a pretty big passionate love for what
music is yeah for us and music is
probably my favorite thing and
especially for you too and Lincoln
parson one of those band that you've
definitely followed yeah all the year
did and for me I remember it since I was
a kid listen kid kid yeah I remember
shaking like a driving to Arizona with a
david henrie yeah and we were like 14 or
something 13 okay and we from Arizona
busy yeah the bandits like the rest of
the guys I think are from Agoura Hills
in California but the chester's from
Arizona yeah and that first time was a
hybrid hybrid theory hybrid theory yeah
that's my for the first album I heard a
Linkin Park was not even that it was it
was the the live album in Texas I think
is really yeah that's my first
introduction to it yeah and you know
their music wasn't necessarily teen
angst or something I mean it definitely
connects to that yeah exactly because
when I was a doing I was a teenager
dealing a lot inks and all these things
I really connected with that oh yeah
it's that like he gets Manchester just
had that voice that were he could sing
all these different kind of notes
and more impressive than the vocal notes
he had this blend of like just legit
singing with heavy metal voice as well
no he is Grimaud who everybody else yeah
no I mean the thing about him is he has
got one of those you know special voices
I feel like like there are a lot of
voices out there there are a lot of
great singers but you can always tell
when Chester Bennington is singing even
you have between soft you know very
sweet singing to you know the gritty
sort of rock and roll singing to the
flat-out just yeah screaming like that
dude had so much vocal range and it
shows in the different if and beyond
that it is emotion yeah boys and we
always got conviction every time you
sing you know when you read up on the
articles of like how he had a drug and
alcohol addiction problems I mean it
does make sense when when you like too
often times it's like when you hear
about artists especially musical artists
you find out they do have a lot of pain
and that's part of what makes their
music sounds so great oh yeah well he's
been pretty open about I mean he's not
only as he had the substance problems
but I know his his family split up early
on and he had believed he was pretty
heavily sexually abused growing up yeah
he's been a is for as hanai admitting
suicide like thoughts of that because of
the fact that he was sexually abused
when he was younger yeah and I didn't
know what had information yeah I'm just
I'm literally I'm just so shocked and
like very much surprised they passed
away oh cool
supposedly he was super closer to his
corner Chris Cornell yeah yeah like just
a future Rhaego accession you know it
was just like a few months in when you
went Chris Cornell died and today was
supposed to be like Chris Cornell's
birthday oh is it yeah that's who
supposedly like that's what linked to
him like actually committing suicide i
boy and I mean thoughts go out to
Chester's family for sure yeah I mean he
has quite a big family yeah makes
children's a lot this is this is a weird
this is a weird thing is this it feels
like finally not finally but um you know
people leave us all the time you know
Culebra teas and and notable people
leave us all the time and
uh you know there's a there's a cultural
conversation is weird discussion about
you know how that affects people you
know everybody feels the need at some
point to come out and be like I don't
care I didn't know that person but like
lately especially than having these
experiences like Anton Yelchin and
especially this like I do feel it like
like you know this dude's art with a
part is a part of my life yeah any more
than it's like more than a decade yeah
Chester's music isn't part of it is
there's no Linkin Park without Chester
yeah yeah there isn't he is he is a
piece of that of their main alchemy T is
the main component him and him and Mike
yeah I mean like I feel like they
balance each other on that scale and
it's you know Linkin Park to me is like
the first I think band that I got really
invested into what I was really
discovering like my taste for sound my
taste for music getting into learning
more than just listening to a couple
singles on the radio and and claiming
that as my favorite band you know
they're they you know helped me breach
into my love of music and they're one of
the bands that over the years you know
you like a lot of people you don't
necessarily keep up with everybody but
you know Linkin Park was my favorite
band back in the day and even though
they're not my top favorite now I've
always kept up with them you know across
the album's and in fact like I've been a
big fan of their push outward you know
experimenting with the sound and I know
Chester's got a lot to do with that
because Chester brings a lot of you know
those rock and those heavy vibes into
the album space and so yeah I mean this
is this is hard is shocking yeah it's
like that's the that's the feeling I
feel in my heart right now yeah it's
like because I've experienced death in
my life before and the first date is
always as a matter of fact today my
dad's death anniversary whole so
you're watching this video and I know
like you guys want like Comic Con videos
to be coming out of this is like an
unexpected video be doing to it so I
have a go to cemetery I don't wanna go
too much of my personal life but I have
to go to a cemetery today so if like
we're late to something please be
understanding if you happen to be
watching this video yeah cuz I have to
stop by there so death but anyway that
this is not an easy subject matter at
all no and I feel that feeling of like
like this is like this thing Skrillex
yeah yeah I'm it feels like it's thing
just goes like a front guard heart
create this weird energy void just right
yeah yeah it's like you know there's a
kid you know there's more feelings
underneath the head under your head
cavity become this weird butterfly you
know hey I think the reason why we
wanted like we don't every time i
celebrity passes away we don't we don't
like do a video about it but
specifically Chester is was such a part
of our childhood and remain throughout
our lives yeah and he was an evolving
artist you know like you hear Lincoln
Park from their first album to the
latest one that came out this year their
music is totally different and Chester's
a main component one of the main
components of that oh yeah and I mean
Anna's dead by Sunrise about his work
with Stone Temple to highlight yes well
he writes the lyrics to it oh yeah I
mean at least for yeah for Lincoln
partners are beautiful lyrics yeah he's
I mean I get the sense that he and Mike
really pound those things and that was
another thing you know you nerding out
of music I bought I remember I bought
the me you're like deluxe edition and
watch that DVD of like the making of and
like you know I came to to know over the
years it sort of yeah especially when it
comes to lyrics they would you know
pour over those things like keep
rewriting them and like you know I say
well you know everyone's opinion on the
music is different but it seems like
those guys always put a ton of work and
a ton of consideration into their into
their craft and I always even even on
the most recent album that that people
haven't been so receptive toward you
know what the pop album I get it even
then you know it's like they're still
pushing and they're still trying new
stuff and you know what it's just so
ironic that I was just thinking of
Linkin Park specifically Chester the
other day I asked Ron to move in with me
kind and a big part of that is like we
wanted to like grow and build stuff
together and the in a big motivation and
what I was talking with John about him
moving in it's like you know those bands
that like this I you know we're going to
live together for a while like a short
amount of time and then we're going to
create some stuff and build some stuff
free
yeah yeah exactly you're right of a
creative environment in your living
space and the first thought I had was an
interview I heard which has Sirhan
k-rock many years ago where I think he
was talking about the minutes to
midnight album and how they all just
lived together recorded and a lot of
times it would just take breaks and play
basketball together like they were the
first one that popped in my mind when I
was talking about that just two days ago
like I remember Lincoln part of a
Chester specifically talking about the
process they did together on that so
yeah I mean I don't really had like of a
gang middle ran for what is V is so
exciting man we're really gonna miss you
Chester yeah they are and I mean from
everything I've ever heard of I wish I
could meet him I'm glad I got to see him
you know play live but you got to see
them live I did yeah I went to project
revolution one year I didn't know that
yeah yeah there's a music festival there
big touring Music Festival and they
headlined they played the end of it and
yeah I mean he's he's electric on on
stage you know and yet from everything
I've heard just a sweet caring you know
yeah great guy ever I don't know you
know these things always pour out in the
wake of this but everything I've ever
heard about that dude has always been
very sweet and very positive and uh and
it broke my heart a little like just 20
minutes ago I was reading a little
article somebody said he just told me
how happy he was like just a day ago or
so and yeah uh you know I guess none of
us know the circumstances but it seems
like these struggles really hide in the
plainest sight sometimes and it's crazy
you know like a lot of times we do
confuse like fame and fortune for
happiness
you know and then you hear something
like this or even like Chris Cornell or
or the countless artists who have made
it like financial success and all that
the tiny world yeah it's like the
depression it goes much further than how
much money you make you know yeah but
yeah thoughts and prayers out to a
little bit if you guys could leave like
positive comments about thoughts and
prayers out to their family
because we wanted to send as much
positive vibes to them as possible
because losing a dad isn't easy I wasn't
losing a dad not even those are six
children right there yeah and Dan I
don't I don't know what led to this but
yeah is all the love in the war Holmes
and I we look in the wake of it
that's a weird relative concept to you
guys but yeah we just wanted to yeah we
love each ester and you're definitely
going to be missed as your important
part of music especially in our lives so
and always I mean you know even your
family it goes without saying if you
need help you know reach out reach out
reach out